Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter une true story.
Une histoire vraie. Quelque chose qui m'est arrivé.
Je vous ai déjà raconté comment j'avais retrouvé mon Mac quand j'étais à Mulhouse et que j'avais perdu dans un train.
Je vous ai également raconté comment je suis rentré gratuitement à Disney Land Paris une fois.
Et aujourd'hui, je vais vous raconter ma plus belle boulette !
Une bonne boulette,
de bonne taille,
que j'ai fait en public, évidemment, sinon ce n'est pas drôle !
Alors je vous le dis tout de suite, je vais changer le lieu, le nom, les dates...
Je vais changer un maximum de choses.
Ne connaissant pas exactement la finalité de l'histoire,
je ne veux pas remettre de l'huile sur le feu si jamais quelqu'un tombait sur cette vidéo.
Je part donc en spectacle, avec Joachim mon diffuseur,  on part faire un show.
C'était très loin de Paris d'ailleurs.
Ça c'est un vrai détail, mais je ne dis pas où. C'était juste très loin de Paris.
Dans un belle salle de 600 personnes où la salle est complète.
Oh ! Tout ça pour dire qu'il était complet !
C'est pas vrai, mais c'est important que vous puissiez retenir qu'il y avait 600 personnes devant moi, qui assistaient à ça.
Dans le spectacle "Fabien Olicard vous mentalise", il y a toujours une personne qui est prise au hasard,
qui vient sur scène, qui doit penser au prénom de quelqu'un, quelqu'un qu'elle connait,
et il faut que je retrouve qui est cette personne pour elle, et quel est le prénom auquel elle pense.
Donc le hasard sélectionne une personne qu'on va appeler Monique,
qui vient sur scène avec moi, qui s'assied sur la chaise qu'il y a sur scène, avec moi,
et on commence à discuter.
Et je lui dis: "Monique, vous allez penser à quelqu'un. Quelqu'un que vous connaissez, n'importe qui."
Elle pense à la personne, j'essaie, un petit peu comme dans les vidéos, de choper des signes, des informations, ce genre de choses.
Et je lui balance une vérité, ce que je pense être une vérité à ce moment là.
Je dis: "Vous êtes en train de penser à la personne que vous aimez. A la personne que vous aimez vraiment."
Et elle acquiesce, elle fait: "Oui, exactement !"
Ah ! Incroyable !
Je suis sur la bonne piste !
Je cherche la première lettre du prénom, je cherche le prénom en entier, je prends mon bloc note, j'écris quelque chose.
Parce que dans le spectacle je fais ça.
J'écris quelque chose sur le bloc note, comme ça une partie du public peut le voir, et attester que je ne change pas.
Et quand la personne dit le prénom auquel elle pense, je fais voir que j'avais écrit la même chose.
En temps normal...!
Puisque pas là !
Je note un prénom en gros. Disons Olivier.
Voila. Je marque "Olivier" comme ça.
Je suis sûr de mon coup.
Mais quand je vous dis je suis sûr de mon coup, je suis certain !
C'est-à-dire que des fois j'ai des doutes. Des fois je me dis: "Ah ! Je suis peut-être un peu à coté..."
Ou des fois même le gros doute, en me disant: "Là je ne l'ai pas,  je pense que c'est très très mauvais ce qui va se passer..."
Quand je rate je ne suis jamais très très loin.
C'est important, vous allez voir.
J'ai mon "Olivier" de marqué en gros sur mon bloc note, et je lui dis: "Quel est le prénom de votre mari ?"
Et elle me répond: "François."
Et à ce moment là, à ce moment précis, je me dis elle me fait une blague.
Elle me fait une blague. Et je garde le sourire, je suis vraiment en train de croire qu'on ait en train d'avoir une connivence, et qu'il se passe une petite blague,
comme ça peut arriver avec les spectateurs rient un peu à mes dépends.
Donc je lui dis: "Mais, votre mari il s'appelle comment lui ? Il ne s'appelle pas François ?"
Elle fait: "Si, il s'appelle François, il est là dans la salle, c'est François."
Et là mon sourire, je le garde, mais il est de moins en moins sincère et de plus en plus crispé.
Parce que je dis qu'il est impossible que je sois autant à coté, c'est sûr, je n'ai pas pu me planter à ce point quand même !
François/Olivier, ça n'a rien à voir !
Donc je cherche, je cherche à quel moment donné ça déconne.
Je dis: "Mais, vous pensiez à François là ? C'est au prénom François auquel vous pensiez ?"
Elle fait: "Ah oui, oui, tout à fait. Je pensais au prénom François."
J'ai fait: "Bon, écoutez, je ne sais pas ce qu'il se passe, mais je suis plutôt sûr de moi."
Parce que j'étais vraiment, vraiment, vraiment sûr de moi en plus à ce moment là.
"Je ne vous le cache pas, j'ai pas écrit François, j'ai écrit Olivier."
Toute la salle se marre, en mode le pauvre il vient de se planter !
Quand je me plante vraiment, je l'admet, je l'assume, et on en rit, je fais des blagues là dessus.
Mais là je n'ai pas envie de ça, parce que non, je ne suis pas d'accord, je ne pense pas m’être planté !
Et je vois aussi dans ces réactions de visage, qu'il y a quelque chose qui cloche.
Donc je lui dis: "Voilà j'ai écrit "Olivier", mais vous pensiez pas au prénom Olivier là ?"
Elle a fait: "Non, non pas du tout, je pensais à François mon mari."
Je vois un agacement, mais pas un agacement logique par rapport à la situation.
J'ai toujours ma pelle, je continue à creuser pour comprendre. [rires]
"Qui s'appelle Olivier dans votre entourage ? Que je puisse comprendre ce qui ne va pas."
Et là, elle se redresse, elle se crispe, elle croise les bras et elle fait "Je ne connais aucun Olivier."
C'est à ce moment précis que j'ai compris ce qui c'était passé.
Je pense que vous commencez à vous doutez.
J'ai fait une erreur dans mon texte, qui a ouvert à cette faille là.
Quand elle cherchait un prénom dans sa tête et qu'elle a pensé à un prénom à un moment donné, j'ai fait "Là vous êtes en train de penser à la personne que vous aimez, à la personne que vous aimez vraiment."
Et plus loin dans le numéro je lui dis: "Quel est le prénom de votre mari ?"
Puisque moi, logiquement, la personne de qui elle est amoureuse, c'est son mari !
Vous sentez l'embrouille venir...
Et toute sa réaction corporelle et d’expression de visage,  m'ont fait comprendre également qu'elle connait un Olivier.
Au moment où elle me dit: "Je ne connais aucun Olivier", je sais qu'elle connait un Olivier.
Et là c'est pire. Parce que ça veut dire qu'elle ne veut pas admettre qu'elle connait un Olivier.
Elle aurait pu essayer de m'embrouiller et dire "Ah oui, j'en connais un."
Là c'est ce refus catégorique d'admettre qu'elle connait cette personne, qui m'a fait comprendre qu'elle le connait justement un petit peu trop bien.
A ce moment précis, j'ai retourné ma veste.
Ah bon il retourne sa veste sur scène ?!
Non, c'est une expression imagée pour dire j'ai changer de direction.
A ce moment là, je m'en suis voulu déjà, et donc j'ai tout repris à mon compte.
J'ai dit: "Olala, en fait je me suis complètement planté, j'étais à coté. J'ai très mal interpréter les signes au départ, je m'en rends compte maintenant.
Donc c'est de ma faute. J'aimerai qu'on vous applaudisse. Bravo à vous. Et désolé d'avoir raté cette étape là."
Et on est parti sur un autre numéro, toujours avec elle pour la remettre en valeur.
Mais au fond de moi je savais ce qu'il s'était passé.
Et alors la seule question que je me pose c'est qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé dans le trajet de retour dans la voiture...
Est-ce que François, son mari, lui a dit:
"Ah bon, tu ne connais pas de Olivier ? Et notre jardinier qui vient sept fois par semaine,
gratuitement en plus c'est très gentil, à chaque fois que je suis au travail, tu ne le connais pas ?
J'espère, j'espère vraiment que je n'ai pas posé de problème dans ce couple là, parce que ce n'était pas le but du spectacle.
En tout cas j'en ai tiré une leçon.
Depuis ce jour, dans le spectacle, je ne parle plus d'aucune informations personnelles.
Et je n'ouvre jamais au global.
Par exemple, je ne dirai jamais "Pensez à la personne qui vous a élevé", mais "Pensez à votre mère."
Je centre les choses sur des informations bien précises, qui sont en général plutôt neutres,
et qui n'impacte pas la vie des gens parce que je m'en suis vraiment voulu.
Je ne crois pas que le public l'ai perçu ça. Je pense que j'ai bien joué le jeu en admettant que je m'étais trompé moi.
Voilà, j'espère que cette nouvelle true story vous a plu.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en laissant un petit...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Comme ça je vous en referai d'autres de temps en temps.
Je ne le fais pas très régulièrement, c'est un peu quand ça me prends ou quand j'ai envie de vous raconter l'une des choses qui m'était arrivée.
Vous pouvez laisser un petit commentaire, je les lis tous et j'y réponds le week-end, à tout le monde, je mets un point d'honneur à faire ça.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner à la chaine, puisque le Mental Vlog c'est quoi ?
C'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !